you have a my screen is telling me that
we're now back on live
Thank You cancer Steptoe I'm just
getting confirmation and that from Sonia
you
members were now put her back in public
session it's my intention members to
take all five recommendations in one go
as proposed to by Kansas nepto and
seconded by Councillor Wharton I will do
one roll call and I would ask the
members if they would not want a
recorded vote as I go through once we
get through to one fifth members to
agree in a recorded vote then there will
be a recorded vote
okay so I shall last two questions one
whether you agree to the recommendations
and it's all five and one and secondly
if you want a recorded vote is that
clear members Kevin could I just clarify
there we think you mean you're going to
ask for with members where they want the
floor a recorded vote before you put the
rest of them oh yes we're going to do it
concurrently so I shall ask the
questions at the same time okay as soon
as we get 1/5 of members requesting a
recorded vote there will be a recorded
vote all right yeah so just to really
reinforce eyes I will ask for two
questions one if you agree with the
recommendations to if you want a
recorded vote is that clear yeah yeah
councilor Belton or the motion and they
require a recorded vote thank you
council person against was that
councillor Burton for my apologies now
so mrs. butcher for the motion and I
don't require a recorded vote
a mission plan tonight first I am
against and I'd like it please okay
mr. Carter counselor mr. Carter for
emotion and against being recorded
Thank You counts the trade I'm for the
motion and against a recorded vote
councillor lefty for the motion and
against a recorded vote
counselor needs standing and mr. Gooding
counsel Hazelwood for the motion nor
record his vote council Hook way and
against the motion and on for a recorded
vote
counselor mr. Hawley against the motion
and for a recorded vote thinking Council
Hudson or the motion I don't require a
recorded vote
Thank You council I owe you I owe new
stain and I want a recorded vote
council Lucas kill all the motion
recorded vote he honestly mrs. Mason
Thank You mr. chairman I'm against the
motion and I'm absolutely for a recorded
vote Thank You counselor Michigan Mike
Fersen Thank You chairman I'm absolutely
for the motion and against any need for
a recorded vote
thank you how's the mr. Merrick
mr. Merrick no counselor milled I'm for
the motion and do not require a recorded
vote counts the Newport against the
motion and for a recorded vote
counselor mrs. Palin chaos a mrs. Palin
motion and I don't need a record you'd
fight you'd counsel mrs. Rowe Thank You
chairman for the motion and against the
recorded votes counselor mrs. Shaw Kara
mrs. Shaw yes we have now enough for
votes for a recorded vote so there will
be a recorded vote I shall now simply
asked if your four against or wish to
abstain in respect to the
recommendations counselor mr. Shaw four
counts of Smith for counter sparing four
counts of Stanley against
it's a step toe or councillor Ward
absolutely for as the web for counselor
mrs. Weston I cants the Wilkinson
against Counsell Williams absolute
before council Wilson against counselor
wooden or thank you I'll come back to
you a second
members there are 24 votes for seven
against three abstentions and that has
been passed remembers that being a last
item on your den gender I thank you for
your participation especially the
outside consultants who with us today
and I close the meeting at 10:00 or 47
thank you very much chairman can I just
congratulate you on the on the meeting
and members thank you for your patience